سأصبح أكبر وأكبر مع أعمالي
، كلما زاد حجم العمل الفني ، كلما
كانت النار
[موسيقى] أكبر ،
اسمي دينا كاتان ، أنا
فنانة ومصممة ،
أتيت من مصر وأعيش في دبي
[موسيقى
] أفعل ذلك بشكل سلس  الفنون تكون الوسيلة سائلة
سواء كانت راتينج
أو كحول أو أكريليك
بمجرد أن تبدأ في مزجها معًا ،
تبدأ في
التصلب وعليك إنهاء ما
تعمل عليه ،
ربما أكون مسيطرًا 70
ولكن الباقي ليس أنا ، إنها شروط أخرى
أحاول أن أفعل تقنيات غير تقليدية
معها مثل النار ، فهذه
هي التقنية التي
أنشأتها يجب أن تكون في الهواء الطلق لأنها
تنطوي على
حريق ، لذا فإن المكان المثالي هو
الصحراء وأعتقد أن دبي مثالية
لذلك ، لذا فأنا أضع ما يكفي  الكحول هنا
لأن الجفاف عادة يكون سريعًا في
الرمال ،
فإن الصحراء في دبي هي بالتأكيد
مصدر إلهام
، وعندما أقوم بعملي الفني في الصحراء ،
أشعر أنني حر لأنني دائمًا
أختار مكانًا
لا يستطيع فيه أحد رؤيتي وهو أنا فقط
وأعمالي الفنية مع الفنون المرنة  تشعر بالحرية
وتشعر أنك تتخلى عنك وتشعر
أنك تسير مع
التدفق وفي الصحراء يتضاعف هذا فقط في
أنا لا أعرف 10 أو 100.